：今天這個案例很有意思。你可能沒想到，在澳洲，一個大學老師竟然靠著AI，幫自己打贏了一場法律訴訟，而且還是針對他工作的麥考瑞大學。
：等等，自己打贏？他不是律師吧？還用了AI？這聽起來有點出乎意料，法律這麼專業的事情，用AI就能搞定？會不會只是剛好矇對了？
：原文裡有提到，這位老師叫格雷戈里·貝克（Gregory Baker），他本身是資訊學術背景。他之前是麥考瑞大學的兼職講師，他想轉成常態性的兼職員工，但學校拒絕了。
：所以他決定自己上陣，不用律師？這膽子也太大了吧。一般人遇到這種勞資糾紛，通常第一時間都是找律師諮詢，哪會想到自己用AI去處理？
：這就是讓我特別詫異的地方。他不是隨便用，原文說他用了多個付費的AI代理，像是ChatGPT Pro這類工具，組成一個「AI法律團隊」。
：一個「團隊」？聽起來很厲害，但具體怎麼做到的？難道AI會幫他寫訴狀、準備辯詞嗎？這有點難想像耶。
：其實就是讓AI幫他彙整資料、跟進參考文件，甚至預測雇主可能提出的反駁論點。你想想看，這不就像有個助理，幫你把所有相關資料都整理好，甚至連對方會說什麼都先提醒你。
：這確實省了不少功夫。不過，他能贏，是不是因為他的案件比較單純？畢竟是勞資糾紛，不是什麼跨國大案。
：你說得對，原文有指出幾個關鍵。首先，貝克老師的案子主要圍繞在一個新的「臨時工轉常態工」法規，這條法規還沒有經過太多案例檢驗。而且，他把爭議點限縮得很窄，只針對他在某個特定課程的教學情況。
：喔，原來如此。還有呢？這跟「司法普及化」有什麼關係？
：澳洲的「公平工作委員會」本身就設計成方便民眾不需要律師也能處理糾紛的平台。所以，這個平台本身的性質也降低了門檻。但重點是，貝克老師能活用AI，讓他在這個「友善」的環境裡，發揮了最大效益。
：那如果是一般中小企業主或上班族，能從中學到什麼？假設我今天開一家小店，如果遇到法律問題，是不是也可以不用請律師，自己用AI來處理？
：我猜啦，對小店來說，如果只是簡單的合約審閱、法規查詢，AI可能幫得上忙。但如果遇到複雜的爭議，像商業糾紛，可能還是需要專業人士。不過，它提醒我們，有些過去被認為是「高門檻」的服務，AI或許能幫我們省下不少前期準備的時間跟金錢。
：所以，它的價值在於「輔助」，讓非專業人士也能初步處理一些專業事務，而不是完全取代。這我信了。那對於我們這些上班族來說，這個概念能怎麼應用到工作或生活中呢？
：其實，就是去思考你工作流程中，有哪些步驟是重複性高、資訊整理需求大，但又需要一定的專業判斷，卻又夠「窄」的領域。像寫報告、市場資料分析，甚至是初步的會議記錄整理，AI都能提供很強大的幫助。
：你這麼一說，的確是。把AI當成一個超級助理，幫我們處理那些耗時耗力的基礎工作，我們就能把精力放在更需要人類思考和判斷的部分。
：對，這個案例不是說AI能全面取代律師，而是展示了「個人」透過AI工具，能達到過去只有專業團隊才能實現的效率和精準度。
：聽起來，這好像也提醒了我們，未來很多專業服務，可能不再是少數人的專利，而是會因為工具的普及，讓更多人能接觸到。